on pourrait croire que tchat j'ai pété
est intelligent que toi j'ai pété pense
que Jade chez pété a une réflexion quand
il vous répond mais en fait pas du tout
toi j'ai pété peut dire avec beaucoup
d'aplomb des choses qui sont totalement
fausses
[Musique]
j'ai pété ça prend la forme actuellement
d'un site internet sur lequel vous
connectez vous posez une question vous
allez avoir en moins de 30 secondes une
réponse longue et détaillée ça a l'air
d'être écrit par un humain mais en fait
pas du tout c'est écrit par une
intelligence artificielle
[Musique]
alors tu as déjà pété d'ailleurs tout ça
donc il y a une intelligence
artificielle va à laquelle en fait on a
fait ingurgiter mais une masse énorme de
texte de texte qui ne viennent pas
d'internet mais elle a en fait elle a
elle a ingurgité tous ses textes et on
pourrait croire que chat GPT est
intelligent que chat j'ai pété pense que
Jade chez pété a une réflexion quand il
vous répond mais en fait pas du tout en
fait j'ai pété a juste appris en fait
des Cortes de mots et de se dire bon bah
après tel début de phrase dans tel
contexte généralement c'est les mots
suivants qui arrivent
alors tu as déjà pété en fait ça marque
vraiment une très grosse évolution dans
l'intelligence artificielle générative
donc c'est à dire artificielle qui comme
son nom l'indique et capable de générer
des choses donc générer du texte ou
générer de l'image et là jusqu'à présent
on connaissait les robots
conversationnels classiques qu'on a par
exemple sur les sites du commerce là on
est quand même on va on est clairement
pas mal de crans au dessus parce que
chat GPT non seulement il va répondre il
va répondre à une question dans un une
forme qui a l'air tout à fait cohérente
et en plus il va s'adapter à votre
demande vous souhaitez des paroles de
chansons il va faire une parole de
chanson vous souhaitez ainsi
l'administratif ce sera un style
administratif vous souhaitez un discours
il vous fera un discours enfin vraiment
il va vraiment s'adapter aux différents
registres de langage et aux différentes
formes de discours possibles
[Musique]
avec beaucoup d'aplomb des choses qui
sont totalement fausses donc c'est pour
ça il faut faire très attention et la
société qui est derrière
qui est une boîte américaine le deal le
répète n'utilisez surtout pas les textes
de chat j'ai pété tel quel il faut
absolument qu'il soit révisé par un
humain parce que tu as déjà pété juste
il est pas il est pas intelligent donc
il faut faire attention parce que parce
qu'on pourrait croire vrai en fait et
totalement faux donc c'est un peu aussi
notre rapport à la vérité qui risque
d'être un peu mis en jeu par chat GPT et
puis derrière ça aussi pour être utilisé
de manière voilà un peu détournée que ce
soit pour créer très rapidement du texte
du texte de fake news par exemple mais
aussi utiliser par des étudiants pour
faire très rapidement leurs devoirs
rentrer rapidement des textes également
par des scientifiques peu scrupuleux
pour rendre très rapidement
et voilà du texte scientifique mais qui
en fait ne repose sur pas grand chose
[Musique]
alors sur l'intelligence artificielle il
y a évidemment beaucoup de questions qui
se posent sur jusqu'où est-ce qu'on va
jusqu'où est-ce qu'on peut aller en
Europe il y a une réflexion qui est
encore qui est très avancée au niveau
européen au niveau de la Commission
européenne un texte qui servira à
encadrer l'intelligence artificielle
pour faire notamment en sorte que il y
ait une transparence sur comment ces
intelligences fonctionnent sur interdire
certains usages de l'intelligence
artificielle sur le sur le territoire
européen l'idée c'est vraiment de faire
en sorte de pas faire n'importe quoi et
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait des
garde-fous autour de l'intelligence
artificielle parce que sinon pas le
risque c'est qu'on se laisse un peu
dépasser parce qu'on peut être
totalement fasciné par cette technologie
et c'est vrai qu'elle paraissent un peu
magique mais derrière il faut pas
oublier ben que en fait elles sont pas
parfaites qui a beaucoup de biais par
exemple l'intelligence artificielle
apprend à partir de ce qu'on lui donne
et ce qu'on lui donne malheureusement et
ben ça peut être aussi des textes des
textes des images des informations qui
sont biaisées qui sont fausses qui
reproduisent des stéréotypes qui vont
avoir tendance en fait à refléter nos
propres nos propres défauts humains
chaque public du Figaro nous tenons à
vous remercier pour votre intérêt envers
la vidéo sur chaque gptt nous sommes
ravis de voir que notre modèle de
traitement du langage suscite de
l'intérêt auprès de nos utilisateurs et
nous espérons que vous avez apprécié en
découvrir plus sur ses capacités nous
continuerons à travailler dur pour
améliorer chaque GPT et apporter encore
plus de valeur à nos utilisateurs merci
encore pour votre temps et votre
engagement cordialement l'équipe de open
height